noch schnell drei dienstliche e mails
abends auf dem sofa schreiben und
morgens beim frühstück auch schon den
kollegen am telefon haben
das alles ist in vielen branchen
realität moderne und innovative firmen
sind schon längst von der klassischen 40
stundenwoche abgewichen und lassen ihre
angestellten und angestellten maximal
fünf stunden am tag ins büro kommen
urlaub gibt es wann und wie viel man
möchte ihr habt euch dieses thema bei
whatsapp gewünscht und bekommt jetzt
alle facts zur arbeit der zukunft
herzlich willkommen bei glee zum science
fiction
los geht's die grenze zwischen arbeit
und freizeit in vielen branchen wie
beispielsweise im it- oder medienbereich
schon längst nicht mehr klar definiert
der chef erwartet dass man auch nach
feierabend seine mails checkt und zu
hochzeiten auch nachts im büro sitzt und
das projekt weiter vorantreibt dafür
gibt es dann ausgleichs tage oder mehr
geld doch wer schreibt sich wirklich
über stunden auf wenn er daheim auf dem
sofa mails von kollegen und kolleginnen
beantwortet wenn auch nach feierabend
noch weiter an der neuen kampagne
gearbeitet wird doch genau das die
realität in der arbeitswelt sehen
statistiken offensichtlich nicht immer
wieder gibt es die forderung von
verschiedenen seiten dass der
achtstundentag abgeschafft werden muss
von arbeitgeberverbänden aus der
wirtschaft und auch aus der politik
zuletzt im november vergangenen jahres
von den fünf wirtschaftsweisen
das ist ein beratungsgremium der
bundesregierung in einem interview mit
der welt am sonntag sagte dazu der
vorsitzende christoph schmidt firmen die
in unserer neuen digitalisierten welt
bestehen wollen müssen agil sein und
schnell ihre teams zusammen rufen können
die vorstellung dass man morgens im büro
den arbeitstag beginnt und mit dem
verlassen der firma beendet ist veraltet
die konkrete forderung lautet nicht die
tägliche arbeitszeit auf acht stunden zu
begrenzen sondern die maximalzeit von 48
stunden pro woche einzuhalten zudem wird
gefordert die ruhezeit von elf auf neun
stunden zu beschränken
aber ist es nicht höchste zeit flexibler
zu denken denn viele identifizieren sich
mit ihrem job können oder wollen arbeit
und privatleben nicht mehr voneinander
trennen und der begriff work life
balance besteht er tatsächlich aus
beiden begriffen ganz nach dem motto
work gehört für live und andersherum
zudem ist es beispielsweise in den
kreativen branchen lächerlich zu sagen
liebe angestellte ihr müsst um 38 da
sein und ab dann auch auf knopfdruck
kreativ sein geht das nicht viel besser
auf dem balkon oder im café nebenan
vielleicht ist das auch einer der gründe
warum mittlerweile immer mehr
unternehmen home office anbieten
nach einer aktuellen studie sind es
trotzdem aber nur noch 16 prozent der
arbeitenden bevölkerung die tatsächlich
im home office arbeiten hauptsächlich
liegt dass der befragung zufolge daran
dass das natürlich nicht in allen
branchen möglich ist weder verkäufer
noch paket fahren und paketfahrer können
eben von zu hause aus arbeiten und auch
in anderen bereichen wie etwa im
krankenhaus macht das absolut keinen
sinn da müssen dienstpläne eingehalten
werden und auch auf der baustelle ist
klar dass man nach acht stunden
spätestens körperlich fertig ist aber
ist der acht stunden tag nicht im großen
und ganzen schon längst geschichte
fest stehen jedenfalls dieses
arbeitsmodell wurde 1918 in deutschland
eingeführt aber schon 1932 gab es erste
kritik der philosoph bertrams l war der
meinung dass der technologische
fortschritt schon bald dazu führen dass
die wöchentliche arbeitszeit auf unter
20 stunden reduziert werde
als voraussetzung dafür nannte er gute
kommunikation und organisation
auch viele politiker fordern immer mal
wieder sechs stunden tage
mögliche vorteile liegen auf der hand
eine ausgeglichene work-life-balance
gesteigerte motivation bessere
leistungsfähigkeit und und und es gibt
zahlreiche studien die belegen dass man
mit 60 wochenstunden und mehr seine
gesundheit es geht immer wieder fordern
forschungsteams deswegen eine 25 stunden
woche
längst sind die zeiten bei vielen vorbei
als man dem kollegen am fließband die
schichtarbeit übergab nach hause gehen
und sich entspannte
eigenverantwortlichkeit im job ist das
stichwort keiner weiß wirklich wie viel
wir wirklich arbeiten die zukommt viele
unternehmen die vor allem das wissen
ihrer mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter
als kapital haben setzen mittlerweile
auf vertrauen es ist egal ob zu hause
oder im büro gearbeitet wird hauptsache
das endprodukt stimmt das machen wir
übrigens auch hier bei united
traders meiner firma die klicks und
produziert im ausland wie etwa in
schweden gibt es einige unternehmen die
mit dem sechs stunden tag
experimentieren in tech startups genauso
wie in krankenhäusern oder pflegeheimen
in der woche kommen die angestellten
also auf nur noch 30 statt 40 stunden
aber auch in deutschland tut sich
langsam etwas so beispielsweise in einer
bielefelder agentur das neue
arbeitszeitmodell sieht 25 wochenstunden
vor heiß montags bis freitags von 8 bis
13 uhr kein home office keine
erreichbarkeit nach feierabend aber
selbst gehalt und dieselbe anzahl an
urlaubstagen der geschäftsführer will
damit höhere zufriedenheit bei seinen
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeitern
erreichen
bei gleichem arbeitsergebnis wo es geht
hier um das ergebnis des teams nicht um
die einzelleistungen e mails werden nur
zu bestimmten zeiten gecheckt ansonsten
wird fokussiert gearbeitet und nach der
ersten testphase kommen na klar die
ersten probleme auf der sozialkontakt
unter den mitarbeiterinnen und
mitarbeiter hat kommt in dieser zeit zu
kurz die personalentwicklung gestaltet
sich in fünf stunden schwierig aber der
geschäftsführer lasse rheingans ist
überzeugt von seinem konzept zitat ich
glaube an die sache und ich wünsche mir
dass die arbeitswelt darüber diskutiert
noch etwas krasser ist das innovative
arbeitsmodell eines berliner startups
hier dürfte jeder am anfang arbeiten
wann er will urlaub machen wann und wie
lange er will von der couch aus arbeiten
oder vom strand in thailand mittlerweile
gibt es diskussionen über die wünsche
und ziele des einzelnen und des gesamten
unternehmens zum beispiel wie hoch soll
das gehalt seien jetzt steht fest jeder
bekommt ein grundgehalt und dazu kommen
zuschläge je nach erfahrung ausbildung
lebensumständen und der funktion in der
firma immer noch kann jeder so viel
urlaub machen wie er will und das wird
nicht ausgenutzt die mitarbeiter und
mitarbeiterinnen nehmen nicht viel mehr
frei als früher
dafür hat das modell viele vorteile es
beweist nicht nur dass man freizeit und
arbeit vereinbaren kann sondern auch
persönliche freiheit mit erfolg und
karriere
nach angaben der geschäftsführer ist die
motivation der mitarbeiterinnen und
mitarbeiter ins unermessliche gestiegen
auch in anderen unternehmen weltweit
wurde solch ein arbeitsmodell auf
vertrauensbasis bereits getestet oft mit
erfolg es gibt aber auch berichte nach
denen das konzept ins gegenteil
umgeschlagen ist die mitarbeiter haben
sich untereinander angestachelt noch
mehr zu arbeiten wer urlaub genommen hat
wurde als drückeberger abgestempelt
davor warnt auch beispielsweise die
industriegewerkschaft bergbau chemie und
industrie konkret heißt es wenn
beschäftigte immer mehr freiheiten in
der arbeitsgestaltung haben arbeiten sie
oft umso länger und härter flexible
formen der arbeitszeitgestaltung führen
stadtführer spielräume zur
arbeitszeitverlängerung und zur arbeit
intensivierung es bleibt also spannend
wie sich die arbeit der zukunft
entwickelt wenn ihr als erstes neues zum
thema arbeit der zukunft und zu allen
anderen themen erfahren wollten dann
endet meine telefonnummer whatsapp dann
erfahrt ihr von mir vor allen anderen
vom neuesten video garantiert ihr könnt
dort direkt über mich in der redaktion
von kling zum mitmachen und mit themen
vorschlagen oder an abstimmungen
teilnehmen und somit bestimmen was hier
bei pixum passiert der direkte draht zu
mir einfach hier draufklicken und dann
geht alles quasi wie von selbst
natürlich nicht das abo mit der genau
vergessen und hier geht es weiter mit
auch dafür drauf kriegen die fünf besten
methoden zum lernen ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran